what it takes so long to talk about that
dragon thing man took me a huge it took
me a long long time to figure out how to
separate that out from the other
archetypes you know it was alright
alright so I'm going to bang through a
bunch of images here and so that's an L
chemical illustration it's really cool
this thing it's weird
so you can see the okay so you can think
about this as a map of psychological
development or you can think about this
as a representation of how potential
reveals itself in actuality and it sort
of works from the bottom up so the first
thing you see there is that container
and if you notice the dragon is emitting
sperm into this thing that's like an egg
so and then this egg thing has wings and
that's the round chaos I was talking
about before it's the container of the
you can think about it you can think
about it as the container of what
matters and one of the ways of really
thinking about of organizing your
framework so that these this way of
understanding can work for you is to
start thinking about the world as being
made out of what matters and then you
come into contact that now and then when
you come into contact with something
that matters now Heidegger had an idea
like this by the way Heidegger was very
interested in he thought Western
philosophy had gone off its tracks in
some sense with with Socrates which I
think is unfair I think what happened is
that Western philosophy developed
immensely in one direction and left some
other directions not very developed so I
don't think it's fair to say that
Socrates like derailed us but he helped
us blow up and really a lot in wonder
but Heidegger said look knots about for
a while it's too rational it's too
limited and it it it misses the central
issue for Heidegger the central issue is
what is being now you might have heard
about David Chalmers you anybody ever
heard of David Chalmers ok so David
Chalmers got famous because he made this
question about consciousness he said
there's the hard problem and the easy
problem of consciousness the hard
problem is is why we are conscious
because his notion which I think is I
don't know what to make of it really
I've never been that fond of it is that
we could just as easily be totally
deterministic zombies machines with no
consciousness whatsoever it's like or we
can't figure out why we couldn't be like
that you know we could build a robot
hypothetically that did everything that
we did that wasn't conscious now maybe
we couldn't but maybe we could so then
what is consciousness and why is it
I think that's formulated that question
is formulated improperly because I think
the hard question is way harder than
Chalmers hard question because the
question of being is a harder question
and the question of being is why is
there anything at all and what is it
that is and and I don't think that's
distinguishable from the from the hard
question because in some sense there
isn't anything without consciousness or
that's one way of looking at things now
so that's the container of what matters
and then out of that that's very that's
as generalized in abstract as you can
possibly get it's it's what's similar
across every instance of what matters
now Heidegger also thought that our
basic orientation to the world was one
of care because he was trying to qualify
our experience what is our experience
like or he would say what is human being
like and one of the things he said is
well it seems to involve care we care
about things or we don't care about them
but but care is central to what it means
to be human and so that the contact
between those
that set of ideas and this is that one
of the aspects of being is that it
matters now sometimes it doesn't matter
at all that's what it appears to be but
it looks like we're still concerned
about what matters we're very hurt when
nothing matters anymore right and I
would say part of what happens when
nothing matters anymore is we're
completely blinded by our map the map is
blinding us completely to the
possibilities of being we spiral
downward as a consequence of that so
what's happening here is that what
matters itself first manifests itself in
this horrific dragon-like form because
it's so because what you don't
understand and what's anomalous to you
is it's certainly capable of devouring
you but it's paradoxical and this is why
these archetypes are also so complex
because logical people always say
everything is either one thing it's not
itself and the opposite of itself at the
same time but and that's a like it's a
prerequisite for for the world that you
can apprehend logically but the problem
with that is is it's wrong lots of
things are what they are and what and
the opposite of what they are at the
same time human beings are like that
like you can hate someone and love them
at the same time no problem and they
could be a hateable and a lovable object
at exactly the same time and life can be
wonderful and tragic and cruel at the
same time it's like so the archetypes
are actually partly there so to help us
represent entities or experiences or
classes of experience that don't have a
logical framework we can't separate the
bloody things out they always confront
us as a as a unity and so the dragon'
figure the predatory reptile is like
that because you might say without the
predatory reptile there's no gold and
then you might ask well is the reptile
worth the gold it's like well maybe the
gold is worth more than the reptile I
mean that's basically what human beings
are betting on you know we're betting
that if we confront the unknown and we
gather the treasure for gathered the
information as a consequence that will
help us beat the dragon there's there's
the the gold is bet is more than the
dragon better be you know but we're
betting on that and that is not terror
management that's a whole different idea
it's a whole different idea it's not a
delusion or an illusion it's a bet and
part of the bad is this is a Kierkegaard
Ian's idea you don't know that's true
but you could live as if it's true and
Kierkegaard would say if you live as if
it's true then it might become true but
you'll never know unless you try to live
as if it's true and that's the act of
faith from a character Guardian
perspective you have to aid priority
decide that that will work and then you
have to follow it and you have to be
willing to see where it leads now I
talked about this in one of my other
classes I think I finally got it right
in some ways this is something we're
thinking about because I think this is
this is a critical choice that people
make so here's two ways to use language
like let's say I'm going to pick up a
girl in a bar all right so I have a goal
in mind and the goal is sort of the girl
is irrelevant to the goal insofar as she
could be another girl so it's it's it's
it's a psychopathic goal in some ways
because really really because the
individual doesn't matter it is I'm
serious about that
it's an so what I'm gonna do say if I'm
a pickup artist I follow these pickup
artists on line a because I'm so curious
about their use of psychology and all
they ever do is come up with it's like a
whole horde of men talking about how to
deceive and manipulate women it's it's
extraordinarily interesting and
extremely psychopathic and and also it's
very very very very very unsophisticated
and unskilled because what the guys are
they're lumps
basically and what they're trying to do
is to acquire the veneer of
sophistication and that's psychopathic
so anyways that's my my little spiel on
pickup artists but they're very
interesting so what they're doing is
teaching their followers instrumental
language and so if you want to sleep
with a girl here's how to do it here's
how to manipulate her you don't they
have a bunch of tricks like where
expensive watch and dress up and also
don't just dress up so dress up rich
roughly speaking but also add something
peculiar to your wardrobe like something
that really stands out as somewhat odd
they call that peacocking so that the
girl can see that not only are you rich
and successful but you've got that
little bit of individuality that sets
you apart from all the other rich and
successful guys you know and so that's
like a no Cyrus Horace combination
basically but it's all because
the guys aren't like that so it's so-so
and then they have all these little
routines they use that are verbal
routines and they have these guys they
go to the bar with to help them with
their little routines and it's like it's
completely what are they doing they're
using language instrumentally they have
a goal in mind which is their goal and
they know that what the goal is and they
know that the goal is right insofar as
they're pursuing the goal and then
they're willing to say anything to
obtain that goal now you think well I
think that's the instrumental use of
language what do you do if you're not
using instrumental language that's
interesting what you do is you try to
communicate about the situation and your
response to the situation whatever it is
as clearly and accurately and
articulately as you possibly can all the
time and see what happens that's a whole
different thing because the proposition
there is to the degree that you're
transforming your experience into
reality into articulated reality the
things that will follow from that will
be the best things that can possibly be
even if you don't know what they are so
there's an openness and in that approach
it's like I'm gonna conduct my
relationship with person X in the most
truthful possible manner and I'm gonna
see what happens and then I'm also going
to assume that whatever happens is the
best thing that could have happened
because like how the hell do you know if
it's the best thing that could have
happened maybe the person's all offended
and irritated I've seen this with my
clients a lot so especially with the
agreeable ones say because they're all
bent out of shape with resentment
because they're not saying something you
know and so
and you know and because they're not
saying something they're getting
shepherded into some situation they
don't want to be in like maybe they're
they have to go live with someone they
don't want to live with and they don't
want to you know express themselves
because that'll hurt someone's feelings
it's like so we talk about that in a
bunch and we figure out how you could
say what you actually think and usually
what happens is they say it they get in
a whole bunch of trouble and then two
days later the problem goes away so
they're afraid to say what they they're
actually using silence instrumentally
basically because their idea is I don't
want to fight with you well so how do I
not fight with you I don't say anything
that will upset you it's like well upset
you win exactly you know like if you if
you're an intimate partner with someone
and you see them doing something stupid
repeatedly that is going to lead them
into a pit in like a month or two months
or a year or five years you don't get to
say well I'm not gonna fight with you
just because that'll be trouble because
sooner or later they're gonna fall in a
pit and that's gonna be trouble too so
you're not doing them any damn favors
you're just for stalling the catastrophe
into the future it's not helpful where
instead you could say well here's how it
looks to me and this is you know how it
looks it looks to me like this is where
this is going and you probably don't
want to go there and even if you do I'm
not going to aid and abet it and then
they're going to get all upset and
they're gonna tell you that you're
interfering and that you're mean and
that you're cruel and that you can only
see the bad and things and if you wished
and all that and they're gonna get
really angry and stomp out and if you
can withstand that then they're gonna
cry and tell you you're you know a son
of a and mean and that they never
want to talk to you again and then
they'll go home and think about it and a
week later they'll come back and say I
never want to see you again probably not
or they'll say geez you know I thought
about that and what you said made sense
and I'm gonna do I'm gonna try to do
something about it so but you have to
decide to begin with whether or not you
whether or not you're willing to risk
the consequences of the truth and that
doesn't mean you get to use the truth as
a weapon I mean that's not truthful you
can use the truth as a weapon you know
if you see someone who's perhaps not as
attractive as
could be you could say your your rather
ugly you know which in some senses of
the truth it's a it's a statement about
but it's not the truth at all because
for it to be the truth it has to be
embedded what it really has to be is
embedded in the Osiris Horus pyramid
you know what the utterance has to serve
the entire function of that integrated
unit it has to serve tradition it has to
serve enlightenment it has to serve
vision and if it isn't doing any of
those things it's not the truth even if
it's the truth in this local tiny slice
you know I I just told you the truth
it's like no you didn't you took a
little fragment of what could be
interpreted to be the truth and you
turned it into a bat and then you hit me
with the bat and then you defended
yourself by a false argument that's
claiming that when you use the truth in
a local manner like that you're actually
moral that's right that's not true it's
incredibly deceptive because you know
the best way to deceive someone is to
sort of tell them the truth and then you
not only you can really get the person
their name because not only are you
innocent because you've told the truth
they're even more guilty because they're
too weak to handle the truth so man you
can really wall up someone with that so
anyways that's the container of what
matters and it first manifests itself in
this potentially horrific form and so
then the question is well are you
willing to confront that and in what way
are you willing to confront it and then
out of that arises at the very top
that's illumination you know it's maybe
the night first I think that's a
crescent moon although I might be wrong
about that I think it's a crescent moon
what arises out of that is the contents
of the unconsciousness and then finally
illumination you know so it's like Horus
are rising from the depths it's a story
of transformation the transformation of
what matters in to illumination that's
what that means
so this is Jonah and what happened to
Jonah roughly speaking is that God told
him he was supposed to go somewhere and
he didn't want to go there and so he got
on a boat and then there was a big storm
and none of the sailors knew why the
storm came up and Jonah finally said
well it's probably my fault because God
told me to go do something and I didn't
want to do it and so God sent this storm
so they take Jonah and they throw him
off the boat you know and he's ok with
that because it's his fault and then the
waters calm and then this big whale
comes up and swallows them and then it
spits them in out on the ground
three days later roughly speaking so
what's the idea there well it's a
complicated one the first idea is that
if you're called you better listen
that's the first idea and you know
people modern people never believe that
they're called to do anything but that's
because they're not very bright and they
don't pay any attention and you know
perfectly well that you're called to do
things because now and then you know
that you should have said something you
know it like sometimes you don't know
should have you said something should
have you not said something you don't
know so fine you're not culpable but
lots of times you bloody well know that
you should have done something or you
should have said something or you
shouldn't have done something or you
shouldn't have said something and you
went ahead and did it anyways well part
of the moral of this story is beware of
doing such things you know if you don't
listen something will come up from the
depths and swallow you and if you're
lucky it'll spit you back up three days
later but it's not necessary that it
will it might just swallow you and that
will be the end of that you know and
I've seen people who are tangled up in
such trouble they don't have enough life
left to fix it and it's usually the
consequence of well I've tried to
calculate it I think it's possible to
make a hundred bad decisions a day maybe
more but certainly a hundred you know
and those hundred just bad decisions are
usually sins of omission they're usually
things that you know you should do and
then you just don't so they're things
you should explore and you don't they're
things that you should say that you
don't there are obligations that you
should undertake and you don't so it's
it's passive avoidance in some sense
it's willful blindness just like the
kind of willful blindness that doomed
Osiris
so it's not active repression it's just
failure to engage when you know you
should okay you do that a hundred times
in a day and it's like 700 in a week and
it's 3,000 in a month roughly speaking
and it's 36,000 in a year and then you
do that for 10 years that's 360,000 so
then you have 360,000 things lying
around you that you have to fix and the
problem is while you would even fix one
of those things when they popped up and
so that's how I am at reappears right
there's little monsters they pop up and
you could whack them with a hammer like
whack-a-mole no problem if you wanted to
but if you don't do that for three
hundred and sixty thousand decisions
then they all aggregate into this
looming chaos monster and the
probability that that thing's gonna eat
you is or that you're gonna live in its
belly because that's where you end up
it's a very bad idea and it's often the
case that people just don't have enough
time and energy left or willpower or
character by that time because they're
destroying their own character they're
they've had it you cannot help them you
cannot fix it they're done they can't be
rescued from hell oh that's easy it's
like it's like it's like remember I told
you about those experiments with the
married couples the ones that are gonna
get divorced they walk into the little
bed-and-breakfast and its hi dear and
with a kind of no no I smile it's like
that's a predatory smile it's like I
kind of like you but these are really
teeth and they're for eating you know
really it's not pleasant and so they're
interacting with each other both of them
are really nice but they're not they're
not nice at all they're carnivorous
right to the damn core and so on the
surface it's all roses and sunshine and
like a little inch below it's all like
their grid like you could see their
unconscious you'd see two people with
their hands around each other's throat
and their body knows that because up
goes the cortisol up goes the heartrate
they're sweating away you know that's
the belly of the beast that's what that
is
and your body it's smart it knows where
you
or your you know you can ignore it which
you do you know it's like oh this isn't
too bad
it's like yeah it's it is it's really
bad it's really really really bad and
you do that long enough it's like good
luck for you
you know you've you've polluted your
psyche and your surroundings to such a
degree that you can't fix it and it gets
worse than that because if you stay
there long enough you won't even want to
fix it you'll be so angry at yourself or
the other person that you're going to
try as hard as you can to do everything
you possibly can to make it as bad as
you possibly can and since you have
virtually an unlimited imagination for
evil it can get really bad so and you
get into a self-sustaining spiral at
some point that's a that's a hellish
descent and the reason that hell is
bottomless is because no matter how bad
it is there's some damn devious nasty
horrible little thing that you can do
that you will do that will make it worse
so you know people who think that hell
isn't real they're just not paying any
attention at all it's plenty real so
there's some other representations of
Jonah luckily he got back up same idea
that wouldn't be in such a spectacularly
successful movie if it wasn't archetypal
to the core and it just relates an
archetypal tale so it's brave man
against horrific beast from the depths
Greek so those are the Greeks going
after the Hydra and you see the circle
at the bottom of the Hydra there that's
like a symbol of infinity and so what
are the Greeks doing they're tackling
infinity well that is what the Greeks
did that's why we still remember those
it's like those characters they were
tough people then there was something
about them that was truly remarkable you
know there was only 25,000 people in
Athens so I don't know what was up with
them but they certainly got this part
right
I guess maybe what was up with them is
that's how they thought of themselves
you know it's like they're not running
away you know you could make a pretty
strong case that if a seven-headed snake
with infinite lengths came rolling
towards you it's like time to head for
the hills
right not like stand there with your
bronze axe sure but it wasn't conscious
it was mimic mimicry which is how you do
it do you know you don't go to a movie
like go iron math because Iron Man's
mythological to the core especially the
Avengers movie it had a brilliant
mythological theme and you don't go
there and watch Iron Man and then come
out and say well let's decode Iron Man
into his you know behavioural micro
elements and incorporate those you don't
do that you're gripped by it you're
gripped by it and the transmission of
information is at a level that's below
articulation it's imagistic so maybe
it's modifying the structure of the
contents of your right hemisphere who
god only knows it's it's embodied you
know that's why you you know what
happens you take a kid out to see a
Superman movie and then you bring them
home what do they want to do they want
to put on a little Superman cape and
wander around being Superman you know
and that's the level at which the
information is being transmitted so that
well what's Superman like well we'll
play that out to the degree that you can
play it out then the Superman element in
so far as you could mimic it now becomes
part of your behavioral repertoire so
did they know what they were doing it
depends on what you mean by know could
they fully articulate what they were
doing no but neither can we so that's
what they knew like they weren't taking
something they knew in an articulated
form and saying let's represent it as a
Hydra and a hero it's completely the
other way around it's like we don't know
what the hell we're doing but it seems
sort of like a guy with a bronze axe
attacking a
snake it's like what kind of snake well
it's an infinite snake with many heads
you know and that would have been a work
of imagination
maybe maybe conscious imagination you
know like because those are artistic
productions definitely but they're
products of fantasy
so this chaos monster dragon breaks
itself into two things that's the
initial differentiation so it breaks
itself into the great father and the
great mother so that's the emergence so
it's the great mother in some sense
emerges first in the great father second
although you can't really say that like
the way the myths work is that three
things emerge at the same time the great
mother so that's kind of the unknown as
you confront it and the great father
which is you as a reader and then the
hero which is you as an active agent you
might say one of those precedes the
other but that isn't how it works and in
the myths that just says no no what soon
as things split that's what they split
into there has to be something there has
to be the interpretation of something
and there has to be the interpreter
those are the fundamental elements of
being and so it's an it's an idea the
fundamental elements of being are
there's a pool of information there's a
reader of the information so that would
be horse iris roughly speaking and then
there's a reader and so think about what
happens when you're reading a book you
know you might say well where is the
book and you say well here's the book
it's this little chunk of wood fiber
it's like well no that's what your
visual system deludes you into thinking
when you're using it that's not the book
at all the book contains patterns
it contains representations of
behavioral patterns and the way that you
interpret those behavioral patterns is
by using the reader that's in your head
which is really that structure that
hierarchical structure that I talked to
about because if you didn't have that in
your damn head you couldn't understand
the book because the only thing that
like if you and I are talking and we're
communicating there's a log we have to
agree on before we can even say anything
about which we might disagree so if I'm
writing a book for you people as the
readers what I have to do is assume a
bunch of things that you know because
then I don't have to say though
things because it would take an infinite
amount of time to say everything that I
need to say so I have to assume that
there's a trillion things I don't have
to say because I already know that you
know them and so then I can play at the
fringes with those things so for example
I can lay out a story about my character
becoming angry and I don't have to like
tell you you know well we could tell
he's angry because his his brow is
furrowed and you know he's starting to
sweat and there's a bad taste in his
mouth and if you're angry that's how you
feel and because you already know all
that so I don't have to bother with that
I can just say you know what you just
set up the situation and poof you know
what anger means you know what sorrow
means you know what love means etc etc
so that's why the reader has to be there
and the thing to read sorry the the
structure the interpreter has to be
there and the thing that's doing the
interpreter interpretation and the thing
that's being interpreted have to all
come out at the same time poof and
that's the the hero the great mother and
the great father so that's how they pop
out now let me show you some cool things
there they are now students sent me the
one on the left that's an ancient
Chinese representation and then that
one's Greek it's so cool look at that
you have the dragon in the background
the snake with the knot in its tail
that's ancient Greek that and that's
it's Chinese it's a very old Chinese
representation and out of the snake pops
the divine parents well why is that well
it's partly because that one of the
primary things that emerges out of
undifferentiated reality for human
beings is the male and the female the
father and the mother I mean that's the
first things you come into contact with
roughly speaking when you emerge out of
the void and that's archetypal we know
who a father is we know who a mother is
it's like that's the differentiation of
the genders what time is it yeah okay
okay well let's leave it there that's
good now we've got into the great mother
and the great father and I'm going to
show you their symbolic representation
and their positive because one of the
things that happens is you get the great
mother and the great father pop up and
the next thing is that they
differentiate again and they
differentiate into positive mother and
negative mother and paused a farther a
negative father and then out and then at
the same time the cross the product of
those two things which is the hero that
also emerges and it's differentiates
into the hero and the adversary and so
then you have you have enough at that
point you have enough Tiff's at
differentiation at that point in terms
of representation that you can basically
encapsulate the whole world and so
that's at the base of our conceptual
structures